[Musik]
dollar meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen die heute zu einer weiteren
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 ich
werde immer direkt mädchen abbauen und
den jungs hier mal eben ganz kurz sagen
dass sie aufstehen sollen du auch und du
auch die fackel hat sich einfach mal
stehen dass wenn ich irgendwo wieder
zurückkehren dass wir genau wissen hier
haben wir mal genächtigt die sache ist
jetzt allerdings dass jetzt eventuell
der ein oder andere vermuten wird mensch
luca der ist gerade erst im dschungel
angekommen da wird jetzt bestimmt in die
richtung alles so ein bisschen weiter
entdecken oder nach hier vorne das ist
ja auch krass aus mit diesen hohen
bäumen und dann könnte ich mir da vorne
und baumhaus dran bauen und so weiter
und so fort ja ich weiss hatte ich auch
eigentlich vor die sache ist allerdings
dass ich heute nacht ich weiß vielleicht
bin ich ein bisschen komisch ich habe
allerdings wieder von diesem projekt
hier geträumt und ich habe mir gedacht
als ich dann aufgewacht bin und ich
schlafe man mit auch vom fenster und das
verhalten eisig kalt dann habe ich mit
rudi angezogen wieder für ein gemurmel
und tee gemacht da dachte ich mir mensch
fühlt sich das jetzt vielleicht klingt
nicht richtig an in der jahreszeit
winter also der gerade mitten im
november mich irgendwie hier im
dschungel niederzulassen in meinem
minecraft projekt ich weiß dass ich es
nicht das echte leben aber ich habe
irgendwie mehr bock hallo ich habe
irgendwie mehr bock oder zwei tafeln ich
habe irgendwie mehr bock auf wirklich
sonnenwald auf so einen tiefen wald und
überall schön alles vielleicht auch ein
bisschen mit schnee machen pa laternen
hin und so süße kleine häuschen bauen
vielleicht ein weihnachtsmarkt süße wege
da habe ich irgendwie mehr bock drauf
ich weiß dass jetzt ein oder andere
denkt der dschungel das ist so ein
seltenes biom dass wir noch voll geil
wenn man etwas machen könnte ja aber wir
sind schlussendlich auch nicht lange
gelaufen und ich hoffe einfach ihr gebt
mir eine chance das ist schlussendlich
so dumm dass jetzt vielleicht klingen
mag man noch mal projekt und ich möchte
die sachen umsetzen auf die ich wirklich
bock habe also ich hoffe ihr seid mir
nicht böse da ich erst mal ganz kurze
time natürlich zurück in meinen waldlauf
[Musik]
alle meine hunde sind tot
aber wir sind in neuendorf das ist aber
nicht das gleiche dorf was wir schon mal
entdeckt haben wir eine katze
was ist denn jetzt los hier
aber okay das
hier ist nämlich tatsächlich genau das
was ich meine aufgefordert sind noch ein
bisschen süß bären kann ich mir noch mal
ganz kurz im spitzen und
und sagt das ist genau das was ich meine
hier vorne guckt euch das mal mit so
einer kleinen lichtung hier vorne hier
scheint die sonne rein wer mir so ein
kleines dörfchen wir haben geht die
sonne die hier so leicht rein scheint
also so was genau so was habe ich mir
eigentlich vorgestellt die mit so etwas
dunklen wald aber dann können wir
überall in zukunft auch so laternen
dranhängen damit hier wirklich nichts
passiert die sache ist jetzt allerdings
dass ich mir wirklich erst mal die
kleine base bauen möchte und das ist
auch das ziel für die heutige episode
denn ich möchte mich hier wirklich
richtig niederlassen
[Musik]
ich habe ein bisschen schiss vor diesem
wären ein paar sekunden später wirklich
nur ganz kurz das wort suchen um
aufzubauen hier kommen vier biblischen
alter hier vorne sind noch ein paar süße
beeren die ich eben kurz gedanken kann
ganz kurz vor euch zur orientierung ich
bin jetzt einfach mal hier vorne worüber
gelaufen also wir sind hier vorne ins
dorf rhein gelaufen ich bin jetzt einmal
kurze durchgelaufen und befinde mich
jetzt hier quasi am anderen eingang
sozusagen von dem dorf die sache ist
dass das ding ja echt ein bisschen
größer ist als nachrüstung ständer ich
würde sagen dass ich mich jetzt einfach
mal hier vornehmen dann brauch ich will
mich jetzt auch nicht direkt ans dorf
rahmen bauen
[Musik]
ich habe eine idee aber
das schaffen wir nicht mehr in der
heutigen folge und das bedarf ein
bisschen mehr vorbereitungszeit was
genau mein plan ist erfahrt ihr in der
nächsten folge die geht übermorgen macht
so eine online die sache ist allerdings
dass ich mir auf jeden fall jetzt
erstmal so eine ganz kleine base bauen
muss das könnte ich theoretisch hier
vorne direkt machen hier neben der höhle
dann setze ich mir hier vorne jetzt erst
mal ein kleines häuschen hin bzw kraft
ich mir erstmal ganz kurz eine werkbank
stell mal kurz eine fackel daneben sie
mich in meiner eichenstämme machen wir
mal eben kurz eine fette kiste sagt
damit ich meine ganzen sachen sichern
kann und generell gehen wir erstmal kurz
schlafen damit hier nicht irgendwelche
komischen monster auftreten die sache
ist allerdings und das hat dieser wald
halt leider ansicht dass halt die ganze
zeit gegen welche sachen bauen können
deswegen müssen uns wirklich beeilen
hier alles irgendwie schön ausleuchten
allerdings mache ich mir erst mal glaube
ich sogar eine zweite tour noch mal eben
damit ich diese wichtigsten sachen von
mir erst mal sichern kann und dann würde
ich euch jetzt auch eigentlich ganz kurz
direkt meine teilnetz einwänden nicht
mehr die ganzen sachen zusammen suche
die ich für mein erstes richtiges haus
benötige
[Musik]
ich treffe meine sachen auf einmal kommt
der kleine idioten
und jetzt wieder weg aber das hat echt
das geile wir sind ja halt direkt neben
seinem dorf kann theoretisch die ganze
zeit mit den handeln können uns hier
richtig geil im venet ihr heide machen
ponyhof hier vorne irgendwie ist hier
gar nichts
ich suche aber weiter wann
immer wir gehen von meinen sachen
[Musik]
leute 2 max
selbst schuld wenn du zu uns kommst
ich finde das nicht so
aber passt auch ganz schönen mundgeruch
zu rücken ein scheiß dorfmann was kann
ich denn dafür dass wir so einen scheiß
creeper in die luft fliegt man denen sie
können den später
wahrscheinlich kannst du dich jetzt ja
auch noch meine mädchen legen alltag das
heißt allerdings dass hier fast schon
wieder nach dass meine lieben freunde
ich habe mir gerade das kriegt man noch
so ein bisschen ausgebessert du gehst
raus hier ich muss dir drin schlafen ich
bin endlich fertig habe gerade jetzt
sage und schreibe 35 minuten
diese ganzen sachen hier
zusammengebracht
sieht nicht so krass aus dafür dass sich
allerdings frisches hier diese welt
erstellt habe ist es eigentlich ganz gut
muss mir hier unten jetzt nur noch kurz
ein bisschen bruchsteine holen hier in
die höhe da müssen wir auf jeden fall
demnächst auch noch mal reingehen oh
mein gott ich
glaube
wir haben
und wieder ein schacht system die sache
ist allerdings dass uns das jetzt gerade
erst mal gar nicht so doll jucken soll
hier vorne geht es auch schneller nach
oben die ganze kohle lasse ich auch ist
mir hier davon habe ich erst mal genug
ich habe mir gerade noch so ein bisschen
buch steigen geholt denn ich muss mir
einen rüstung ständer machen und ja ich
weiß der andere aufmerksame zuschauer
wird schon erkannt haben da hinten steht
eine rüstung ständer bei diesem schmid
die sache ist allerdings dass ich da
nichts clown möchte deswegen hier vorne
neben kurzen glatten stein herausnehmen
die platten steine verwandeln wie jetzt
hier zu sechs platten steinstufen und
die platzieren wir jetzt einfach so
hierhin mit den steckern wo das wir dann
hier eine rüstung ständer bekommen nun
haben wir auf jeden fall alle items
fertig den rest packe ich immer ganz
kurz eben wieder rein und mit diesen
sachen kreieren wir uns jetzt erstmal
ein sechs mal sechs großes feld jetzt
ist halt die frage wo ich mich genau hin
weil ich hätte ehrlich gesagt bock
darauf mich hier vorne direkt dran zu
bauen weil wir dann direkt hier am haus
am dorf sind hier vorne ist auch seinen
pflichten baum dann habe ich hier vorhin
gepflanzt weil ich ein bisschen was
heißt missen ich brauchte eine menge
pflichten hallo
ich habe das nicht so richtig mit diesem
doch
noch weg
[Musik]
ist das
das heißt dass abgeschnitten naja gut
also ich würde sagen wir bauen uns
einfach mal hier vorne mit dran würde
ich sagen von daher kreieren wir hier
direkt 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 x 1 2 3 4 5 6
großes feld lassen natürlich jede
richtung und dann gehen wir hier in der
mitte auch noch mal ein vier mal vier
großes feld tiefer in die tiefe die
unten kommen jetzt fichtenholz bretter
rein und außen rum platzieren wir
fichtenholz stämme nun ziehen wie diese
pflichten holzstämme hier insgesamt drei
blöcke hoch so dass wir dann an den
seiten die rinde der fichten holzstämme
entfernen können und sogar hier in der
mitte zwei mal etwas frei lassen können
um dort gläser einzusetzen ich
wiederhole jetzt hier auch auf der
anderen seite zack zack zack zack zack
zack zack und zack den hier habe ich
falsch gesetzte ich gerade den selbst
noch mal ganz kurz neben neu drauf das
sind natürlich auch selbstverständlich
alles seine richtigkeit hat fakten den
er wieder abbauen und hier auch in die
mitte diese beiden blöcke entfernen so
dass wir hier auch wieder glasscheiben
einsetzen können und hinten lassen wir
das so da machen wir nämlich keine
glasscheiben rein warum erfahrt ihr
gleich wenn wir uns ins interieur
kümmern und zu guter letzt können wir
uns nur die vorderseite wo wir diesen
bereichen drinnen werden und diese
beiden blöcke hier raus nehmen werden
weil wir der aneinander wird zwischen
denken hier natürlich unseren eingang
drin haben und das hier ist dann quasi
unser eingang zu unserem ersten kleinen
häuschen nun können wir uns ums dach und
da habe ich mich so ein bisschen auch
anhand meiner alten map dran her
gerangelt weil ich das ja auch immer so
gebaut habe das dach jetzt muss ich mich
allerdings trotzdem an der seite kurz
bei ihm hoch bauen denn hier kommt jetzt
auch wieder eine bruchstein treppe drauf
hier nun eine bruchstein stufe so dass
wir langsam hoch gehen können dann hier
jetzt zwei bruchsteine dran und hier
vorne auch wieder eine bruchstein stufe
darunter auch eine bruchstein stufe hier
vorne das ganze gleich machen wir hier
vorne wieder also quasi wieder hier eine
bruchstelle treppe dann können wir die
erde wieder wegnehmen hier eine
bruchstelle drei mal wieder ganz kurz an
der seite hoch bauen so dass wir auch
hier eine wurfscheibe daran haben das
gleiche wiederholen wir jetzt auch auf
der anderen seite eben da
ich darf immerhin diese blöden wären
rein wiederholen das ganze jetzt auch
hier vorne ganz oben auf der anderen
seite dass das ganze hier dann
schlussendlich auch genauso aussieht wie
vorne und jetzt kümmern wir uns hier um
diese da werden wir nämlich erst möchte
hier auch bruchstein treffen dransetzen
nun allerdings die ganze hier so dran
setzen hier auf der anderen seite genau
das gleiche und generell auch gleich
noch mal auf der rückseite also auf der
linken seite hier vorne und dann setzen
wir vorne wieder die bruchsteine stufen
so auf dass wir hier so einen kleinen
keine anhebung haben sage ich mal und
genau das gleich wiederholt auch auf der
anderen seite nun zwischen wir
allerdings von unseren steinen wie
darüber zu unseren fichtenholz stufen
fichtenholz treppen und fichtenholz
brettern denn wir bauen jetzt hier das
dach mit fichtenholz weiter können
allerdings und das ganze ein bisschen
rustikaler aussehen zu lassen wir vorne
auch zwischendurch so bretter dransetzen
einfach also beispielsweise hier vorne
auch wieder beim und dann setzen wir zum
beispiel hier vorne auch wieder an
fichten holzbrett dran damit einfach so
ein bisschen hier generell in diesen
nicht ganz perfekten wald passt der
idiotischen derzeit aufnahme generell
alle die hier wohnen einfach irgendwie
die noch recht junge mann peter vorne
geschlafen hier oben ziehen wir jetzt
auf jeden fall fichtenholz stufen von
der einen seite zur anderen seite und
bauen schlussendlich auch hier auf der
seite alles so ein bisschen rustikaler
jetzt habe ich idiot natürlich keine
pflichten holztreppen da muss ich mal
ganze eben runter laufen zu einer
werkbank allerdings können wir dann hier
vorne beispielsweise noch fichtenholz
besetzt und jetzt den rest einfach mit
den treppen hier zukleistern wird dass
unser dach natürlich auch regenschutz
fest ist hier vorne bei euch jetzt
allerdings diese stufe wieder ab um hier
bruch steiger draufzusetzen fange ich
jetzt wahrscheinlich warum ganz einfach
das ist unser schornstein und den
kleiden wir auch ein wenig ein also hier
oben erstmal ein lagerfeuer drauf und
jetzt können wir unsere fichtenholz
falltüren nehmen und die hier an der
seite dran packen und dann die ganzen
teile einfach hier ein klappen so dass
es so aussieht als werden dieses ding
wirklich komplett normaler schornstein
der macht es natürlich keinen sinn
vielleicht etwas auf die seite hier
setzen ich glaube wenn ich diesen blog
entfernen dann geht auch hier das meiste
weg und unser lagerfeuer kann entspannt
in den himmel hoch steigen ich könnte
jetzt natürlich noch darunter einen
heuballen setzen so dass wir einfach
alles so ein bisschen ja noch paar
kratzer haben mit dem lagerfeuer die
sache ist allerdings dass das erstmal
ausreicht ich möchte in der nächsten
episode bocken und viel holz sie einfach
lied ich möchte in der nächsten episode
mir ein bisschen was anderes bauen bin
auch hier schon mal anderthalb stunden
also ich muss im gottesstaat machen
ich liebe diese modifikation nun kümmern
wir uns allerdings ein bisschen um
dekoration da machen wir nämlich hier
vorne runter zwei bruchsteinmauern
setzen hier unten fichtennadeln dran und
anteilig hier ein paar süße beeren hin
pflanz und dass wir mal eine kleine
nahrungsquelle haben die sie noch
nachher ziemlich süß aussah hier hinten
gerade alles noch so ein bisschen offen
ist werde ich hier vorne einfach
fichtenholz seine platzieren und hier
sich den holzzaun tore quasi zwischen
diesen beiden wir vorne platziere ich
nun ein fass mit einer kleinen laterne
drauf denn hier in dem bereich werden
uns eine kleine farm anlegen für kräftig
mir nehme ich mal ganz kurz neben der
hatte die ich mir gerade schon gemacht
habe auch noch einen eimer mit dem wir
uns dann irgendwo her wasser holen
müssen
aber wir haben hier nichts was a doch da
vorne ist eine kleine quelle und das
geil ist halt daran dass ich in dieser
java-version her spieler dass ich quasi
gleich einfach eine kleine stufe über
das wasser setzen kann so dass man es
dann nicht erkennt hier vorne müssen wir
allerdings jetzt erst mal eine kleine
quelle haben auch ein fuchs hier vorne
kann ich mir dann auf jeden fall mal
ganz kurz ebenen wasser einmal raus
nehmen ich find das echt so süß ja alles
ist zwar gerade noch ziemlich düster das
kann ich nachvollziehen die sache ist
allerdings dass wir ja alles wirklich so
schön bunt werden ich werde eine menge
bäume hier fällen so dass wir wirklich
eine kleine siedlung haben und unser
häuschen man sich auch schon so leicht
sehen lassen hier vorne kann ich jetzt
nämlich mit meiner eisenachs eben kurz
den fichtenstamm abbauen letztlich den
wassereimer hin und nehme mir jetzt
einfach meine fichtenholz stufe und kann
die hier so drüber setzen das heißt hier
ist trotzdem wasser drin und ich kann
jetzt allerdings dennoch meine erde
wieder nehmen die hier hinsetzen und mit
meiner reisen hatte ja alles so ein
bisschen
bepflanzt so dass es trotzdem wasser
bekommt jetzt nehme ich meine kartoffeln
unser ziel hin weil gebratene kartoffeln
machen wirklich die die ballade
ordentlich rein ich habe heute auch noch
nichts gegessen habe ich hunger die
restlichen kartoffeln die eisen hacke
und meinen eimer platziere ich jetzt
einfach mal hier rein das wird generell
so ein bisschen eine weitere kiste und
ich kann ja dann einfach mal
die ganzen sachen reinpacken die ich so
es auf der anderen seite des hauses
wiederholen wir jetzt einfach mal das
ganze prozedere setzen als ich hier auch
wieder die fichtennadeln hin und hier
vorne eine süß wäre und hier auch die
hier habe ich jetzt natürlich falschen
gesagt super jetzt hab ich noch nicht
mal eine schere dabei also ganz gut mal
eben hier mit der schere das ding
abbauen so dass ich hier vorne jetzt
perfekt richtig hinsetzen kann und jetzt
bauen wir uns ganz kurz die vorne mal
eben hoch beziehungsweise können wir
auch das ganze erst mal ganz kurz eben
von innen machen denn hier kommen jetzt
auch erstmal noch zäune dann also hier
hier hier und hier und auch von außen
natürlich selbst wahrscheinlich die
pflichten holzzaun tore perfekt direkt
fall spaziert genauso wie auf der
rückseite vom haus auch ich werde es
glaube ich generell so machen dass sich
diese beiden fichtenholz stufen hier
entfernen und durch fichtenholz bretter
ersetzt so dass das so ein bisschen
abgeschnittener aussieht und das hier
nicht so in der luft irgendwie drum
clijsters wohnt hier vor dem eingang
platz den wir jetzt auch zwei süße
beeren nämlich hier und hier und hier
vorne auch nochmal zwei mauern wo wir
dann auch zwei laternen draufsetzen
jetzt kommen wir allerdings endlich zum
interior design und zwar benötigen wir
hier drinnen erstmal zwei fichten
überhaupt richtig herunter gehen können
was ich jetzt auch noch machen werde ist
hier alles einfach ausgleichs wagen
damit dass wir hier oben nicht hier so
ein komisches komisches loch drin haben
und ich werde meine leiter nehmen und
hier vorne nicht nur daran setzen mit
einem leitern dran und jetzt noch einmal
ganz kurz eben zurück zu unseren items
und nehmen unser weißes brett mit denn
das können wir jetzt perfekt genauso wie
in unserer ersten base ja so ein
bisschen underground mäßig war hier
vorne darauf setzt das war nicht ganz
cool weil wir da so ein bisschen so ein
hochbett hatten unserem bett nimmt immer
so viel platz ein also hier können wir
das hinsetzen und dann hier
beispielsweise ein blumentopf mit einem
fichten setzling drin und hier noch eine
laterne damit wir haben auch so ein
bisschen beleuchtungen haben und den
platz perfekt ausnutzen und hier drunter
packen jetzt unsere beiden schmelzöfen
unseren normalen ofen und drei rote
teppiche so das ist ein bisschen
wohnlicher aussieht die werkbank werde
ich jetzt einfach mal hier unten
platzieren damit wir so ein bisschen
platz sparen und hier vorne wenn wir den
rüstungs ständer hinhauen und hier vorne
unseren amboss und jetzt nutzen wir
wirklich jeden platz außerdem wir
irgendwie kriegen können und platzieren
hier vorne unsere fässer dran und auch
die genau das gleiche nochmal hier eben
auf der anderen seite darunter beziehen
jetzt fichtenholz falten so dass das
auch so ein bisschen abgeschnittener
aussieht weil das sicher auch wieder
findet in unserer kleinen hochfest
situation hier vorne und dann haben wir
es damit jetzt auch schon geschafft
meine lieben freunde von außen sieht das
ganze haus so ist es ist etwas sehr
klein aber es ist ja auch unser erstes
eigenes haus unsere kleine start-ups
hier vorne haben wir unsere kleines beet
dahinten wir haben überall süd bären an
den ecken herum und wenn man reingeht
haben wir den platz wirklich komplett
ausgenutzt und können hier vorne alle
unsere items reinpacken ich werde das
jetzt noch mal ganz kurz sortieren das
werde ich euch jetzt nicht einblenden
dass ich werde diese ganzen items nehmen
und einfach hier vornherein packen das
wenn wir einfach deutlich zu langweilig
wenn ich das euch jetzt zeigen würde
allerdings würde ich an der stelle des
heutigen wir jetzt auch beenden wenn es
euch gefallen hat und wenn euch meine
kleine base hier vorne gefällt dann lass
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert meinen kanal und
klickt auf die glocke wenn der neue
videos dieses projekt minecraft mit luca
staffel zwar nicht verpassen wollte
morgen um 18 uhr kommt erst mal auch ein
anderes video online da spiel ich mal
wieder break out also ein kleines rätsel
spielt aber übermorgen geht es dann
weiter mit meiner kleinen missionen dort
hinten etwas zu bauen das kann man jetzt
gar nicht so richtig erkennen die sonne
ist auch wieder untergegangen allerdings
ist das auch das perfekte zeichnen das
heutige video zu beenden wir sehen uns
rein
[Musik]